welcome to this video playing do it's
now ok I'll do it from from Sweden 96
quite amazingly popular those kind of
setups yeah well at least they give
black gum give black gum yeah some
unconventional play ok so it should be
to see one yeah I ray often play this
kind of set up against against this this
Chi Gorean type of system it's not it's
not brilliant for white but it's it's
fairly fairly solid and easy to play
yeah my intention was be should be hive
but after Bishop f3 I actually have to
take with the Jeep on see ya then td5
wasn't really successful yeah ok yeah
well now exactly he gets he gets this in
leading to to quite them quite a nice
position typical off the Queens gambit
declined they are trying to use those
some wood week squares before playing
for before it's not so great yes he gets
the light square Bishop trade it now but
okay it's not the end of the world and
easily playable position yeah I rather
have two nights when Bishop an idea
now the Queen feels a bit uncomfortable
here let's attack this night that's
playing ping typically fast they all
play really really quick now I don't
like the Queen's right here with the
slide weaknesses on the queenside this
might still be something and if he takes
my pawn structure will be strengthened
with the Jeep on taking on f4 yeah I
expected that really so probably not any
good but does not want to trade Queen's
g4 I can still play this yeah yeah of
course some kindergarten trick I was
just seeing it after a play G form
yeah it's fairly typical this kind of
tricks offer of those of this kind of
opening it's pretty much relies on those
kind of those kind of moves
yeah it is a very bad now I are losing
actually it's just losing after 94-92
was the big threat which is the Queen
even so I needed to do this no he can
take with the poem and then everything's
hanging exchange it now this is also
possible the pawn is easier but this is
also good after that I'm two points down
check but I will continue no reason to
resign check
it's two points but it's also a look at
game so there are always some chances I
objectively I'm lost and completely lost
but but you never know yeah okay for us
quite mysterious but okay
I probably will play rook to be three
but it's not doing much actually but
okay
okay let's trade off this rock and then
see if I can quickly get in with my rook
yeah I want to provoke the King back you
can actually prelude create know and and
enter here okay it's a check I have
continued that far i might as well it
might as well play on and so let's see
killa maybe enter him
Yahoo p3s not not helping much really
check your non-threatening rook g8 it's
not you cannot cannot advance on the
pond there maybe you can giving up just
one of the pawns
check
time warning
hmm she actively is lost of course but
he already made the number of an
accurate move so why not continue it was
totally lost on the outset and no I'm
somewhat active at least I can oh no no
I'm starting to play for a win him at
least him I'm not worth any more I think
she's 65 there all week yeah I know I'm
just better him it's a draw
unfortunately but
really would have liked to to punish
that let play but not possible I guess
check check
check
27 seconds check check check check check
yeah this wasn't the greatest end game
ever I guess but I simply couldn't bring
myself up to resign this game and you
really managed to lose this w-end came
with two pawns and the better position
quite remarkable and now he lets the
clock run down maybe you're disconnected
I really don't know black forfeits on
time yeah this was some yeah of course
somebody embarrassing for both sides i
mean my g4 move was was really terrible
blunder I really I saw it right when I
when I moved it meso 94 this is
instantly losing really instantly check
check check yeah this is a double rook
endgame with two pawns and no
compensation whatsoever and it's still
of course a total win yeah what exactly
did he do wrong I mean check a beefy
five I don't know but ok it's still
winning of moss I'm not trying to tell
you that there is anything great
happening here check but the road here
it started to get a bit tricky you can
take pee tube of course check here maybe
f4 after this I don't know after after
this it's it's not so clear really maybe
a form we look at this can he can he do
that technically
trying to push the pawn computer gives
black a flat-out win so it is probably a
win but we already is already a bit
inconvenient for black and channel here
we are now we are already in a draw in
the draw territory check until widest
better but he managed to to get to this
I'm a beer okay tour but he has got to
be three okay yeah well it is it wrong
of course yeah but he simply didn't
didn't didn't set up the simple drawing
drawing mechanism I mean around here
just roo k 6 is of course the draw I
mean the typical six ranked defense and
we continued a bit still at all but here
it is not anymore because i get i get in
he must put it on f7 and and stay put I
really don't know jack no I just winning
check check yep check get to this a d7
would've won instantly but i only have
27 so it is still when I can always
build the boot the bridge here and now
you just blunder to look maybe mouse
live or anything yeah here in outer a
bit of complications and and then didn't
manage it i mean he had two minutes left
so there are ways to just play it
without allowing me any girl to play
yeah therefore at some point you know i
don't know many many ways okay thanks
for watching